so we want to give you guys just one
more example of a transformation before
we move on to the actual calculus of
multivariable calculus in the video on
parametric surfaces I give you guys this
function here it's a very complicated
looking function it's got a
two-dimensional input and a
three-dimensional output and I talked
about how you can think about it as
drawing a surface in three-dimensional
space and that one came out to be the
surface of a doughnut which we also call
a torus so what I want to do here is
talk about how you might think of this
as a transformation and first let me
just get straight what the input space
here is so the input space you could
think about it as the entire TS plane
right we might draw this as the entire t
axis and the s axis and just everything
here and see where it maps but you can
actually go to just a small subset of
that so if you limit yourself to t going
between 0 so between 0 and let's say 2
pi and then similarly with s going from
0 up to 2 pi and you imagine what you
know that would be sort of a square
region just limiting yourself to that
you're actually going to get all of the
points that you need to draw the torus
and the basic reason for that is that as
T ranges from 0 to 2 pi cosine of T goes
over its full range before it starts
becoming periodic sine of T does the
same and same deal with s if you let s
range from 0 to 2 pi that covers a full
period of cosine a full period of sine
so you'll get no new information by
going elsewhere so what we can do is
think about this portion of the TS plane
kind of is living inside 3-dimensional
space this is sort of cheating but it's
a little bit easier to do this than to
imagine you know moving from some
separate area into the space and the
valleys for the animation efforts it's
easier to just start it off in 3d so
what I'm thinking about here this square
is representing that TS plane and for
this function which is taking all of the
points in this square as its input and
outputs a point in three-dimensional
space you can think about how those
points move to their corresponding
output points ok so I'll show that again
we start off
the TS plane here and then whatever your
input point is if you were to follow it
and you were to follow it through this
whole transformation the place where it
lands would be the corresponding output
of this function and one thing I should
mention is all of the all of the
interpolating values as you as you go in
between these don't really matter a
function is really a very static thing
that's just an input and there's an
output and if I'm thinking in terms of a
transformation actually moving it
there's a little bit of a little bit of
magic sauce that has to go into making
an animation do this and in this case I
kind of put it into two different phases
to sort of roll up one side and roll up
the other it doesn't really matter but
the general idea of starting with the
square and somehow warping that however
you do choose to warp it it's actually a
pretty powerful thought and as we get
into multivariable calculus and you
start thinking a little bit more deeply
about surfaces I think it really helps
if you you know you think about what a
slight little movement over here on your
input on your input space would look
like what happens to that that tiny
little movement or that tiny little
traversal what it looks like if you did
that same movement somewhere on the
output space and you'll get lots of
chances to to wrap your mind about this
and engage with the idea but here I just
want to get your minds churning on this
pretty neat way of viewing what
functions are doing